that's it you've got your degrees but
don't leave just yet I do have a few
words to convey to you but before I go
any further congratulations again to the
parents and families for all the support
and love and confidence you've shown
your children in these past four years
or five years this is truly a wonderful
day for you you have every right to be
proud of your children who have
accomplished something important here
and I want to thank you for entrusting
your children to us for the past four or
five years during that time they've
contributed much to this university and
for that we're very grateful and
congratulations to you the terrific
class of two thousand nine you really
are a great class no one knows quite
what makes one class different from
another I think it may have to do with
the major events that shape your time
here for your class in addition to the
usual elements of campus life that
marked the Carnegie Mellon experience
booth buggy superb cuisine the light
workload your time in fact can sided
coincided with some major historic
events Katrina hit New Orleans just as
you were starting classes without a word
of complaint you made room in your dorms
and your classes labs and studios for
dozens of students from too late and you
did much more showing great empathy and
I think a sense of community
responsibility that was to characterize
the rest of your time here and the way
you engaged issues on campus to the
things you did during spring break in
places like Nicaragua
panama in ghana as well as new orleans
professor randy pausch gave us last
lecture at the beginning of your junior
year and he died last summer Randy who
made his last public appearance last
year right here at this very moment
touched millions of people all over the
world for you and me for Carnegie Mellon
people it was personal and I ran deep
touching the very core of what defines
our community you participated in a
national election to a degree that no
Carnegie Mellon class ever had before
and of course the collection produced
and historical result you turned out for
our campaign launched an impact weekend
in mob sac quinto and that was before he
was mr. Spock and I have to mention for
completeness even though it was
mentioned already if for nothing else
that you happen to be here for two Super
Bowl victories by the Steelers you have
no idea what paying that cause causes a
native of Cleveland Ohio like me but
that's the topic of another speech in
any event to steelers victories
something not enjoyed by carnegie mellon
class for three decades whatever the
forces that have made your class what it
is it's been wonderful to have you here
you've made Carnegie Mellon a better
place and you've raised the bar for the
classes that will follow you I have to
say it's a good thing that you're such a
strong class because the world will need
you even more than Carnegie Mellon has
unfortunately your senior year also have
to coincide with a financial crisis in
economic downturn of epic proportions
and of course valid then cope sessions
bad but that's not all there's a whole
set of challenges many of them
long-standing which were now starting to
confront head-on there is a state of the
environment especially global warming in
a sense that it really is time past time
really that we own up to the problem
then there's the high cost of healthcare
and a Medicare and Social Security
system whose future is very uncertain
and there's a new world order where it's
no longer the g7 but the g20 who must
come together to seek collective action
and an international sphere with active
wars threats from long-simmering
tensions and from groups who are not
nations or subject to any rule of law it
may seem that this may be just about the
worst of times with challenges daunting
beyond measure but in another sense this
is an exciting time filled with
opportunity for those skilled enough and
confident enough to take on the
challenges are you ready the class of
2009 I say absolutely yes and let me
tell you why I thought about this
actually really have and so has Howard
Gardner the acclaimed education
theorists who spent a lifetime thinking
about the diverse intelligences and
strengths human beings bring to their
lives recently professor Gardner
proposed at higher education schools
today should be to develop what he calls
five minds for the future five kinds of
learning that he sees as essential for
the century ahead this may be daunting
for some institutions but not for
Carnegie Mellon and not for you
when you hear about his five minds
you're going to think professor Gardner
has spent the last four years living in
our steam tunnels the first mine
professor Gardner seizes essential is
the Disciplinary mind the achievement of
mastery in some field or skill that as
you know is the foundation of our
curriculum here with centers on
attaining excellence in your major
taking a deep dive into one subject and
getting really really good at it
employees are always telling me how
Carnegie Mellon grads are ready to work
from day one with skill sets already in
place you wouldn't be sitting here today
without having attained this
disciplinary mind already the second is
the synthesizing mind synthesizing mind
which professor Gardner says is the
ability to integrate ideas from
different disciplines or spheres into a
coherent whole and to communicate that
integration to others interdisciplinary
work is of course a Carnegie Mellon
trademark one which is expressed in
everything we do here some of you
combine disciplines by double majoring
in two very disparate things Chemical
Engineering and psychology computer
science and Chinese Studies chemistry
and Hispanic studies Business
Administration of philosophy art
anthropology and human-computer
interaction short of double or triple
majors you took subjects that complement
and inform each other by computer
science and biology a robotics & design
and you collaborated on teams like those
of you who took you to creative
integrated product development with its
project groups of designers marketers
and engineers and building virtual
worlds which brings together artists of
all sorts with computer scientists and
engineers some of you are musicians and
actors whose sole art forms are
inherently collaborative we value
collaborations so
highly because a single discipline can
rarely solve an important problem acting
on its own or as Eric put it the group
is always smarter than the individual
that's why working on interdisciplinary
teams to build solar houses or robots or
video games or plays has been such an
important part of your experience here
the third mind is the creating mind at
Carnegie Mellon we're very proud that
the arts are at the heart of our
university by creativity is by no means
limited to cfa people alone we view
creativity as the capacity to ask new
questions try something new to innovate
these things characterize every
department and all that we do here at
carnegie mellon john hall our graduate
who won the Nobel Prize for Physics a
few years ago echo that when he recalled
his own experience as a student dr. Hall
said that the essential Carnegie Mellon
teaching is fearless ly trying something
new that is creativity and whether you
studied it in mathematics or
architecture or French or triple major
in all three you have practice that here
the last two minds are less about skills
than they are about relating to other
people but they are critical
nevertheless the respectful mind
recognizes and appreciates differences
among people in groups of people I dare
say that whoever you are and wherever
you're from you encounter people at
Carnegie Mellon very different from
yourself you probably made friends with
some or work together on a team project
or played together on a sports team
shared interests are a great tool for
generating respect I'm very proud of the
way we recognize and respond to
different points of view on this campus
from courses like global information
systems management and Arab American
encounters to deliberative democracy and
decision-making to public forums about
conquer
sees that affect our community these
thoughtful approaches the building
community are the foundations of the
respectful mind which as Gardner says in
our fractious and interconnected world
has never been more crucial finally
there is the ethical mind in light of
the excesses and unethical behavior that
seemed to have marked the current
economic crisis this element of your
preparation seems especially timely you
had a chance to ponder ethical questions
within your own majors and you were
confronted with moral dilemmas that you
will face as finance ears managers
engineers designers actors policymakers
chemists or whatever path you choose I
find it very reaffirming that ethics
classes here at Carnegie Mellon continue
to be in very high demand a sure sign
that you appreciate the importance of
ethics and ethical behavior you show
this also not only with your response to
Katrina and in your Spring Break
activities but also with your incredible
amount of community service in schools
hospitals and social service agencies
that you performed every single week
with your devotion to raising money for
charities by selling mountains of Krispy
Kremes or flipping pancakes on the cut
in a snowstorm or any number of other
goofy schemes like cow pie bingo my
favorite but also in a very serious way
including things like the moving
candlelight vigil that took place one
evening in response to the killings in
Mumbai last fall that was the ethical
mind at work the Disciplinary mind the
synthesizing mind the creating mind and
the respectful and ethical mind the
world needs people who can summon the
skills from all of these five domains of
learning
those who can are in a superb position
to recognize and realize opportunities
for change in progress and no one is
better prepared for this than you are a
marvelous Carnegie Mellon class of two
thousand nine this won't be easy but
then again this wasn't easy either we
have great confidence in you
educationally you are the complete
package ready for success and impact in
a way that few others are you've made
this university a better place and you
will make the world a better place too
we're proud to call you Carnegie Mellon
alumni on behalf of the entire Carnegie
Mellon community congratulations and
thank
you